ein bisschen dürfte sie sich fühlen wie
eine agentin irina rosa kowa sie ist
unterwegs im auftrag des lebens des
überlebens
kann nicht das zeug für die hände
benutzen
selbstverständlich bedienen sie sich die
rina kontrolliert für die stadtpolizei
von jaroslawl cafés einkaufszentren
bäckereien wie diese
die verkäuferinnen hier trägt eine
schutzmaske und handschuhe kunden die
ohne maske kommen können sich eine
nehmen das ist alles auf hohem niveau
und alle kunden werden informiert wenn
nötig das hier gibt es keine verstöße
täglich neue corona negativrekorde in
jaroslawl in allen städten russlands
besonders in der hauptstadt moskau
russland erstickt jeden tag mehr als
1000 tote die vierte corona welle größer
fataler als alle zuvor
die zahlen sind erschreckend aber wir
haben keine vorstellung wie erschreckend
sie wirklich die zahlen sind vermutlich
drei dreieinhalb mal höher als angegeben
pressetermin im kinderkrankenhaus von
chabarowsk 8000 kilometer östlich von
moskau eine andere welt dasselbe problem
wir müssen in den zweiten stock wie in
dieser serie mit game alexej nikolai ist
serien fan und chefarzt der
kinderstation in der poliklinik nummer
eins von rhabarber
hat heute nur einer unserer patienten
37,8 schauen sie mal her das ist die
zahl unserer kranken fast alle zimmer
belegt
noch sind sie nicht überbelegt aber wenn
es so weitergeht sind sie es bald zu
wenig ärzte zu wenig sauerstoff zu wenig
personal aus vielen krankenhäusern
russlands gibt es diese meldungen wie im
vergangenen winter
das ist die mutter von dem kind das so
schwer erkrankt war
wir sind am freitag ins krankenhaus
gekommen inzwischen fühlen wir uns gut
aber am freitag ging es meiner tochter
sehr schlecht sie hatte epileptische
anfällen
[Musik]
die mutter ist geimpft und bei ihr wurde
co wird nicht nachgewiesen und beim kind
beim kind wurde es natürlich
nachgewiesen
sie hatte hohes fieber bis 40 grad es
ging ihr sehr schlecht
sie lag zwei tage auf der
intensivstation sie hatte krämpfe das
war schlimm und beängstigend sie bekam
infusionen wurde behandelt
jetzt ist alles wieder normal sie ist
gesund und fröhlich
[Musik]
die delta variante lanciert nach wie vor
12 bis 13 prozent aller patienten sind
minderjährig manche sterben sogar am
virus
wenn man die dynamik vergleich mit dem
vergangenen jahr dann ist das eindeutig
so dass heute kinder und jugendliche
deutlich öfter erkranken
menschen mit berufen im gesundheitswesen
wie alexej nikolajew verdienen wenig und
sind doch helden dieser pandemie allein
1100 ärztinnen und ärzte sind seit
corona ausbruch in russland gestorben an
oder mit corona
brauchen sie batterien oder was irena
rosa kober ist in jaroslawl inzwischen
mit einer kollegin unterwegs auf der
suche nach verstößen gegen hygiene
auflagen wissen sie wie ernst die lage
in der stadt ist und im ganzen land
der kioskbesitzer bleibt entspannt steht
aber auf und holt sich eine masse setzen
sie die maske richtig auf was die beiden
kontrolleuren ausfechten ist ein kampf
gegen windmühlen regeln gibt es in
russland viele abstand halten maske
tragen handschuhe
nur wenige halten sich daran eines der
kernprobleme
viel gravierender aber ist das thema
impfen nur 34 prozent der 146 millionen
russinnen und russen sind vollständig
geimpft
hier herrscht immer noch der kult der
starken männer die vor nichts angst habe
ein zweiter aspekt ist dass die
politische freiheit in russland extrem
eingeschränkt die leute glauben dass sie
ihre kleine insel der freiheit
verteidigen können indem sie keine maske
tragen und sich nicht impfen lassen
und so entsteht eine kultur des imf
widerstands verbreitet vor allem im netz
mit humor oder ernst oder absurd
zwangsimpfungen führen zu so was und wer
hat schuld daran
also ich habe mich gegen korona impfen
lassen keine nebenwirkungen alles gut
alles normal
die staatliche propaganda hat lange
vermittelt das von corona virus keine
große gefahr ausgeht dass es nicht
schlimmer sei als die grippe es gibt
unter den gegnern nicht nur bürger ohne
spezielle ausbildung
sondern auch ärzte
was also können sie bewirken die emsigen
kontrolleuren in jaroslawl in dieser
atmosphäre
sie können fotos machen von angestellten
ohne maske können mahnen stellen sie
masken zur verfügung sie können das ein
oder andere bußgeld verhängen kämpfen
gegen windmühlen eben